NOT CLEAR WHO WAS BEHIND IT.
>> FORMER RUSSIAN KHEGS GRAND
MASTER AND CHAIR OF THE HUMAN
RIGHTS FOUNDATION AND RENEW
DEMOCRACY EFFICIENCY.
THEY ONCE SAID THE "TITANIC"
WOULD NEVER SINK.
THERE APPEARS TO BE
PSYCHOLOGICAL WARFARE GOING ON
HERE.
>> YEAH.
IT IS BOTH PSYCHOLOGICAL AND
HUGE MATERIAL DAMAGE AS TOLD BY
YOUR CORRESPONDENT FROM KYIV.
THERE IS A CELEBRATION IN
UKRAINE.
IT WILL MAKE RUSSIAN WAR EFFORTS
MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
AND ALSO I'M WATCHING NOW THE
REPORT FROM OCCUPIED CRIMEA,
TELEPHONE CHANNELS OF PANIC.
PEOPLE TRYING TO BUY FOOD, FUEL.
RUSSIAN TOURISTS ARE STUCK
THERE.
IT IS PANIC.
IT CREATES EVEN MORE PROBLEMS
FOR RUSSIAN WAR EFFORTS.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT THE
EXPLOSION TOOK PLACE IN THE
UKRAINIAN TERRITORIAL WATERS ON
THE SIDE OF THE BRIDGE THAT IS
ON THE UKRAINIAN SIDE OF THE
STRAIT.
AND IT'S ALSO EARLY MORNING.
FOR ME THAT'S THE BIG
DIFFERENCE.
PUTIN'S ARMY IS SHELLING
UKRAINIAN CITIES.
AND ATTACKING INFRASTRUCTURE.
TRYING TO MAXIMIZE DAMAGE FOR
CIVILIANS.
THIS ATTACK TOOK PLACE AT DAWN.
IT WAS DARK.
THERE WERE ALSO NO CARS THERE.
THOSE WHO CONDUCTED THIS TRIED
TO MINIMIZE CASUALTIES.
THAT IS ANOTHER INDICATION THAT
UKRAINIANS PROBABLY THE MOST
LIKE LE.
>> THIS HUGE PIECE OF
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT PUTIN TOOK A
LOT OF PRIDE IN.
THERE WERE ALREADY FEARS THEY
MIGHT USE NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
IT IS THE HIGHEST SINCE THE
CUBAN MISSILE CRISIS.
I GUESS IT'S HARD TO FIND AN
OFF-RAMP WHEN BRIDGES ARE BEING
BLOWN UP.
>> IT'S WRONG LOGIC.
IT IS NOT ABOUT BRIDGES.
IT IS ABOUT OCCUPATION OF
UKRAINE, GENOCIAL WAR.
THE ONLY WAY TO END THIS WAR IS
LIBERATE UKRAINE.
I DON'T THINK THERE ARE ANY
TALKS OF RESTORATION COULD BE
POSSIBLE.
AS FOR PUTIN'S BLACKMAIL
THREATENING TO USE NUKES, WHAT
CAN WE DO?
IF YOU GIVE NOW, HE WILL USE THE
SAME BLACKMAIL AGAINST NATO
COUNTRIES.
I DOUBT ANY GENERALS HAVE ANY
APPETITE TO DIE.
THEY ALL KNOW THERE IS A CHANCE
THAT AMERICAN TOMAHAWKS WILL FLY
BACK IN A FEW MINUTES.
AS LONG AS AMERICA DEMONSTRATES
ITS RESOLVE TO EXTERMINATE ANY
RESPONSE FROM A NUCLEAR ATTACKS,
USING CONVENTIONAL METHODS,
ADMIRALS AND GENERALS WILL NEVER
PUSH THE BUTTON.
>> INTERESTING.
AND WE'RE STARTING TO SEE -- ON
THAT NOTE, WE ARE STARTING TO
SEE SERIOUS DISSENT OF RUSSIANS
TO THE WAR.
THEY ARE SAYING A CLOSE ALLY OF
PUTIN THAT HE SHOULD KILL
HIMSELF.
LET'S LISTEN.
>> Translator: IT'S TRUE.
MANY ARE SAYING THAT IF THEY
WERE THE MINISTER OF DEFENSE WHO
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS DEBACLE,
THEY WOULD SIMPLY BLOW THEIR OWN
BRAINS OUT JUST AS A TRUE
OFFICER SHOULD.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THE NOTION OF A
TRUE OFFICER IS A FOREIGN
CONCEPT FOR MANY.
>> AND A TOP RUSSIAN STATE SPIN
DOCTOR MAKING CLEAR HE DOESN'T
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING
EITHER.
>> Translator: THERE'S A LOT OF
FISHY STUFF GOING ON.
THE CAMPAIGN SO FAR, TO PUT IT
MILDLY, HAS NOT GONE SO WELL FOR
US.
>> HOW REMARKABLE IS IT TO SEE
THIS DISSENT OR AT LEAST PUBLIC
QUESTIONING OF PUTIN AND WHAT IS
GOING ON RIGHT NOW IN THE WAR IN
UKRAINE?
>> IT'S A VERY SIMPLE
EXPLANATION.
UNLIKE TUCKER CARLSON, THEY
RECOGNIZE THEY ARE LOSING THE
WAR.
AND ALL THESE COMPLAINTS OF
TRYING TO FIND A SCAPEGOAT.
THEY LOOK FOR MILITARY.
THEY LOOK FOR LOCAL COMMANDERS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY THERE IS
ONLY ONE CONCLUSION.
THE WAR IS GOING IN THE WRONG
DIRECTION FOR PUTIN'S RUSSIA.
UKRAINE IS WINNING.
HOPEFULLY THEY WILL RECEIVE
ENOUGH WEAPONS TO FINISH OFF THE
ARMIES BEFORE NE